The Joe Rogan Experience please tell
people your credentials what your
background is
sure so you know my name is Ryan Graves
um I have an engineering degree
mechanical and aerospace engineering I
promptly left doing that to go fly uh
f-18s for the Navy as soon as I
graduated college did that for about a
decade both operationally in combat as
well as an instructor role teaching the
new students
and you know we did witness something
while we were flying in our Jets but
um you know we were doing it under we
witnessed it in the context of our just
everyday flying and our missions
and what year was it that you witnessed
this so we started seeing these in 2014
was the earliest that I know 2013 late
2013 early 2014. and could you describe
what was the very first experience yeah
so uh for me personally the experience
was simply just uh flying out to the
area like I would any other day instead
of seeing an empty airspace with just my
wing person or another Squadron doing
something a different block they're all
sudden a lot of different radar contacts
which is immediately a problem because
you know we could be hitting one of
those or someone working in our area
and this was happening because we
upgraded our radar the best we could
tell we were in a earlier radar called
the apg-73 and we had come back from
deployment we ended a maintenance phase
it's called we kind of do a little bit
less flying upgrade the Jets if we need
to do any long lasting maintenance and
and we upgraded to the apg-79 which was
a much better radar and what is the
difference in the capabilities of the
upgraded radar system versus the
original system so you know kind of
practically speaking it's like going
from an analog TV essentially to like an
OLED it's you know a digital modern Tool
uh compared to more of like an analog uh
classical radar that has more limited
range and has uh less ability to track
multiple targets and things of that
nature so just generally speaking we
would expect expect to see you know more
objects if there were any out there or
smaller objects but
um there shouldn't have been any objects
out there and so how far offshore are
you when this is all going down
our working area start about 10 miles
off the coast and then it goes out you
know 100 or 250 miles or so although we
don't usually use those Far Eastern
areas but we would only see them over
the water so they would really only be
in our working areas
um maybe slightly you know in between
the working area the land but never over
the land sometimes Over The Bays that
are in the area that are quite large
but never just kind of zoom in West over
land or anything like that and is this
restricted airspace it's not so that's a
tricky question for us operating in a
military operating area it is not
restricted in the sense that you have to
be there's only one person allowed in
there you could have these little
Cessnas kind of bumbling in there but
they would get called out pretty quick
um both from the kind of air traffic
control agency that's working out there
as well as f-18s and the other
um aircraft that may be working out
there but in a broader sense when we
look at it in relation to our air
defense identification Zone which is
essentially a band of air space that
surrounds our entire country if you are
uh if your flight path originates out
over the water outside of that it is and
you proceed into that Ada's into our
controlled airspace then you do have to
essentially have permission to enter
that airspace it's not a restricted
airspace like a traditional bombing
range but it is protect airspace it's
our it's our Coastal layer so you have
this upgraded radar system and what are
you detecting
so on the radar really what we can learn
from that is essentially the kinematics
of the object so where is it essentially
and you know what directions are going
how fast is it going things of that
nature we can't necessarily make up the
shape or things of that nature so it's a
representation it's like a a block on
our screen to show that information and
so when we see that on our radar
um
we can tell you know where it's located
you know perhaps what's located around
if there's other objects we're detecting
how fast it's going what direction it's
pointed in what direction it's traveling
in so we call that velocity Vector so if
we see this this essentially a little
circle have a tail coming off of it and
that that tail kind of represents the
nose of the vehicle at least as its
flight path is going and so with that
you know we would typically see an
aircraft just kind of trudging along
with a straight line taking occasional
turns
um but these objects had a little bit
um more of a I don't say random but more
um less controlled uh flight path that
velocity Vector would kind of jump
around a bit more uh they would not
proceed in like a perfectly straight
line as you would imagine like a a
flight navigation computer would take
you right it takes you from A to B in
the straightest line possible these
objects seem to kind of be moving in a
direction that was
not a straight line but generally
proceeding in that direction and so they
would kind of be Meandering slightly but
moving in that general direction both
three-dimensionally and horizontally so
winding around going up going down so
they're not on a flat plane and they're
not going in a straight line so I don't
want to draw too many firm statements
like that because we would see them
being flat too we'd see them perfectly
stationary up there regardless of the
wind really
yep wow so what kind of wind are you
talking about oh gosh I mean at altitude
you can have anywhere up to 120 knots of
AirSpeed which is what is that in miles
per hour it's about 130 140 miles so
they're completely stationary with a 140
mile an hour wind correct how would
something do that that's confusing to me
as well uh even if we had something that
could just burn that much energy right
like if you had a sphere surrounded by
little Rockets right just imagining
something right now okay and if you
wanted to keep that perfectly stationary
right against
um gravity you could just fire all the
rockets at the bottom really fast and
hopefully keep it flat right right it's
gonna have tiny little variations and
then if you have wind hitting it and all
this you could potentially have those
Rockets try to counter it but it would
never be perfectly still and wins like
that because the wind's not perfectly
still either right exactly it changes
and varies it does so it's almost like
it's the wind it's not even really
fighting the wind it seems you know it
just seems like it's it's just there in
a way wow so the first time you see
these things what are your thoughts
yeah the first time really was well you
know what is this right it's not a UFO
or something mysterious at this point
it's at what we're thinking at this
point we see on the radar is just well
our radar is broken right
um these perhaps don't represent
physical objects yet because we hadn't
you know visually seen these or seen
them on our camera yet and so you know
we kind of like hey you know what's
going on here you know is anyone else
seeing this kind of thing but not really
like investigating it right it's just
kind of like all right there was stuff
out there but
maybe next time we'll take a look but
the way our systems work when we have
all this all these contacts on our radar
and if we kind of just select one out
with our little cursor there all our
sensors go to it our flear goes to it
which is our camera system
all their weapons they have like their
own little eyes in some sense and they
all look in that direction and So
eventually you know someone had one of
these selected and flew close enough so
that as they look at their flare system
their camera they could see something
that was at the spot represented on the
radar right so there was something there
so they were seeing it visually with
their own eyes not at this point just on
the the flear system the flare system
and so that's a it's a regular camera
and also an infrared camera and so
typically we'll roll around in infrared
just because it returns a better image
typically so
so yeah you know it didn't look like an
object they were seeing on the Fleer
just looked like a source of ir energy
in a sense almost as if someone was
shining a flashlight but something had
to be there to be reflecting that energy
or creating it so at this point to
answer your question now we're like okay
this isn't just an error in our radar
this is perhaps you know we're thinking
this is real we have to really respect
this as like a safety hazard now even if
it's just a small you know I I you know
however a small ribbon of tinfoil right
like that suck down the engine can still
take out an aircraft right so we have to
be very respectful like a mylar balloon
type thing potentially right yeah but
how fast are these things going
so sometimes stationary right sometimes
they would be going around 0.6 to 0.8
Mach which is at altitude about you know
240 to maybe 330 knots you know around
there so somewhere in the range of an
airplane yeah in a fighter aircraft
would be kind of flying around at those
air speeds except sometimes they would
be perfectly stationary as well right so
it's not exhibiting any sort of patterns
that you've recognized in the past uh no
they have actually so although with the
stationary no right correct with a
stationary no with the Meandering kind
of flight path no but I would also see
them essentially fly what we call a
racetrack pattern and essentially what
that means is they fly in a straight
path and then they do like a 108 degree
turn in a certain direction
then they fly a straight path then turn
again you know so that's what we call a
racetrack pattern as opposed to a
circular holding pattern
we did witness racetrack patterns in
fact I think there's been some cases off
the West Coast just past couple weeks
where people have also been observing
objects flying in racetrack patterns
high altitude with lights so I do
recognize that behavior but I don't
necessarily that mean I don't
necessarily think that means we have to
attribute it to normal behavior
necessarily that type of flight path is
important because it's a very efficient
way to fly right if you have to maintain
the position in a certain area
you want to minimize how much you're
turning because anytime you're turning
in an aircraft you're using more energy
than if you're just flying straight and
level
and so by having a race track pattern
it's an efficient way of of holding in a
position by maximizing straight and
level time
and minimizing your turn time and how
long would these things stay up there
for
so from my experience from our
experience and again we weren't studying
these but they were always out there you
know they're all out there when we took
off we'd see them and then we go to land
they would still be out there like every
day every day every day every day so you
guys go from not having any idea that
these things are out there to upgraded
radar system to seeing them every day
yeah
what is the thought like what how are
you feeling when these like is there uh
an evolution of the thought pattern of
how you're addressing these things and
thinking about them initially you're
thinking they're errors when do you
start getting a thought the like what is
what the [ __ ] is this thing yeah
so that happened when we visually saw
one and the first time we visually saw
one uh the object was directly at what
we call that entry uh point of the area
so you know that box that I told you
about in the sky that starts 10 miles
off the coast there's a particular GPS
you know location and altitude where
incoming traffic will fly in
and outbound traffic will fly in the
exact same spot but uh will fly out a
thousand feet lower
um there were two aircraft from my
Squadron vfa 11 and we flew or excuse me
they flew took off as a flight of two uh
that means they're essentially flying
into formation like this and as they hit
the area one of these objects went right
between the aircraft
the lead uh air crew saw the object the
dash 2 aircraft crew did not which is
not surprising because they're usually
you know you're very focused on flying
formation you're just staring right at
that aircraft the lead really has actual
leeway to look around so
uh he saw it and you know he immediately
came back I have to assume he didn't
have it on his radar because he wouldn't
have flown through this object at the
working at the entrance Point
um he flew he turned around flew back
landed and I was in the ready room when
he come back and
you know he had all his gear on which
typically is not a good thing uh because
you want to get that stuff off as fast
as possible so usually means you know
there's a problem of some nature uh and
you know he was just sitting there
saying hey you know I almost hit one of
those damn things and we all knew what
he was referring to even though we
didn't actually have a name for just
because we were seeing these so much
um and he described it you know he
described it just as a black or dark
gray Cube and that Cube was inside of a
clear translucent sphere uh and
essentially the the Apex or the corners
of that Cube best you could tell uh were
touching uh that inside of that sphere
and that description mirrors many of the
descriptions that people have had of
these whatever you want to call them
whether they're calling them uaps now
for some strange reason UFOs is a
I don't know does it have a dirty
connotation to it as it tainted because
of so many crazy people talk about UFOs
is that what it is it does come with a
lot of assumptions baked yeah it's baked
in that's yeah so that's something but
whatever it is that is a design that
people have reported seeing before that
this translucent sphere and this Cube
can you see through the cube
not to my understanding no so it's some
sort of solid black Cube that's inside
this translucent sphere and it's just
floating around and flying around the
sky
so you know that's that's a good point
is it floating around is it flying
around it's doing both which is strange
right because you could think of that
description okay that's kind of some
kind of weird balloon maybe with stuff
in it and that's that's certainly you
know one way if you just view that angle
of it then it it seems explainable but
when that you know the balloon-like
object starts cruising around at you
know 0.8 Mach you know that that
nullifies that particular
um
idea and you'll see you'll see that a
lot where it's not just like that one
picture that one Behavior it's really
kind of to zoom out a bit and look at
everything in relation to each other and
say okay why is this weird you know okay
it was hanging out in a racetrack
pattern that's not exotic but when you
you learned it was doing it for you know
perhaps 13 hours 13 hours you know
perhaps they were out there all the time
you know so you know
I land and I go back and we weren't on a
a um Intel mission to analyze these
right we're going to do our training
it's very expensive 30k an hour to fly
these things right so really the only
time we can put energy into looking at
these things when we're kind of
transiting back and forth or waiting for
a fight to start uh and so you know it's
never like a dedicated analysis